violencia saqueos y decenas de
detenciones la ira aumentó entre los
partidarios del ex presidente jacob zuma
después de su ingreso en prisión el
pasado jueves los disturbios se
produjeron principalmente en la
provincia de huaraz hulu natal pedimos
que el señor sumar reciba un indulto
presidencial especial con carácter de
urgencia para que sudáfrica pueda
estabilizarse esta situación no es
agradable ni correcta
cientos de personas desafiaron las
restricciones por el coronavirus en
johannesburgo en la provincia de water
aquí la policía también realizó
detenciones y el tráfico se paralizó en
una de las principales autopistas cerca
de la prisión donde está recluido suma
esto después de que se incendiaran
camiones
y los camiones han estado ardiendo desde
que llegue la policía bloqueó los
camiones por un lado pero los
manifestantes vinieron de otra dirección
y siguieron quemando la baches aunque la
tensión parece haber sido provocada por
la detención de zuma condenado a 15
meses de prisión por desacato al
tribunal las protestas están también
relacionadas con las dificultades
económicas que sudáfrica se enfrenta a
fuertes restricciones bajo una tercera
ola del brote de kobe 19
no toleraremos ningún tipo de actos
criminales no toleraremos los actos de
vandalismo aquellos que están envueltos
en los actos de violencia serán
detenidos y judicial izados huelva
en prostitutas
el gobierno ordenó el despliegue de
tropas en las provincias afectadas por
los disturbios dijo que las mantendrá
dependiendo de la situación en el
terreno
zuma se ha negado a cooperar con un
equipo que investiga la corrupción
durante su tiempo en el poder